-You guys, whenever I get
some downtime here at the show,
I like to go on Instagram and
scroll through all the photos.
And one thing I've noticed
is that a lot of times,
two people will write
the exact same caption,
but the pictures they post
will be completely different.
I'm gonna show you what I mean
in this next segment.
It's time for "Picture This."
-♪ Picture this, picture this,
picture this ♪
♪ Yeah, picture this ♪
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
A lot of energy in that song.
It's just nothing but.
Like, "Vooooh!"
-♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Picture this ♪
[ Laughter ]
Alright, let's take a look
at this first example.
Arnold Schwarzenegger
and Jared Kushner both wrote,
"This makes my blood boil."
Arnold Schwarzenegger posted
a picture of the Capitol riot.
Jared Kushner posted
a picture of garlic.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This next one is
from Disney+ and CBS.
They both wrote, "Get ready
to enter a trippy new world."
Disney+ posted a picture
of the new Marvel series,
"WandaVision."
CBS posted
a picture of Theraflu.
Oh, yeah, that's real deal.
[ Applause ]
That stuff is real deal.
Here's one from Tom Brady
and Rob Gronkowski.
They both wrote,
"You're my other half."
Tom Brady posted
a picture of Gisele.
Rob Gronkowski posted
a picture of his legs.
[ Laughter ]
Well, it is -- He's right.
It is his other...
This next one is from
Ben & Jerry's and Rudy Giuliani.
They both wrote,
"Don't tempt me."
Ben & Jerry's posted
a picture of a dog
staring at the new Ben & Jerry's
dog-treat ice cream.
Rudy Giuliani posted
a picture of himself
staring at the new Ben & Jerry's
dog-treat ice cream.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hmm.
♪ Picture this ♪
[ Laughter ]
Do it one more time?
[ Drumroll ]
-♪ Picture this, picture this,
picture this ♪
♪ Yeah, picture this ♪
[ Laughter ]
This next one is from
HBO and Governor Cuomo.
They both wrote, "The city's
about to get sexy again."
HBO posted a picture of the new
"Sex and the City" reboot.
Cuomo posted a picture
of himself getting vaccinated
in a muscle tank.
[ Laughter ]
Ow!
This next one is
from Kyle Busch and Uber Eats.
They both wrote, "Love
the smell of burning rubber."
Kyle Busch posted
a picture of him racing.
Uber Eats posted a picture of
a toasted sandwich from Subway.
[ Applause ]
This next one is from
Nancy Pelosi and Betsy DeVos.
They both wrote,
"Piece of cake."
Nancy Pelosi posted a picture
of her impeaching Trump.
Betsy DeVos posted
a picture of a piece of cake.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Alright, here's the last one.
It's from Barack Obama
and Donald Trump.
They both wrote,
"If there's one thing that
matters to me, this is it."
Barack Obama posted
a picture of his family.
Donald Trump posted
a picture of...
Wait a second.
Never mind.
He couldn't post anything.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's all the time we have
for "Picture This."